[Music]
as the Ukrainian counter-offensive has
got underway tensions and dysfunction
have emerged among the Russians
directing the war
now that Ukraine is bringing the fight
to the Russians what impact will it have
on a leadership in Moscow that's already
feeling the pressure
the infighting has actually started and
it's only going to intensify
[Music]
inside Russia the government is Keen to
project a sense of business as usual
even as the war starts to hit home
Russian Capital getting a first-hand
sense of war after an alleged drone
attack
here they're trying to ignore the
Ukrainian counter-offensive unfolding
hundreds of miles away
but within Russia's Elites cracks are
starting to appear
increasingly I think the talk and this
is what I'm getting from whatever
sources I um still in communication with
on the ground in the Russian Elite that
they are definitely losing haven't
already lost confidence that this war is
winnable or that any of the aims even
though Putin has actually never properly
explained to the country what is it that
he's trying to to achieve that this was
a good idea and those aims however vague
they are can be achieved that Russia is
on on the March I mean the fact that
it's Ukraine that's on the offensive is
shaping the mood I think that
realization is uh sinking in uh amongst
the elite both the technocratic elite
but also of the more militant uh part uh
you know the precaution the Wagner
groups they're the reticles
is the leader of the Wagner group a
private military organization whose
brutal mercenaries have been called on
by Putin to bolster Russia's severely
depleted forces
but the collaboration between
precautions militia and the Russian
military establishment appears to be
unraveling
the infighting uh is I think has has
actually started and it's only going to
intensify and he is turning on the on
the army
foreign
Chiefs are very important because he is
basically blaming them for being
lukewarm he's blaming Russian Elite for
not doing enough
and basically saying this is not the way
uh to fight an all-out War which which
he wants to see I think that sense of
the objectives of this War uh were
unclear from the very beginning and
there's certainly unwinnable as in
Russia is not going to get to Keith is
really sinking in and and pregosian and
as the elites and precaution is part of
that Elite are starting to prepare for
the moment where they will have to
concede some losses of territory what
progression has basically been
channeling from the beginning is that
Russia needs full mobilization it needs
to bring martial law needs to call this
a war not a special military operation
my son says there is a real uh
intensifying of different factions
around Kremlin and it's uh fighting with
each other and this is out of the
ordinary I mean Putin has always ruled
through saying conflict between his
cronies but he doesn't like this being
you know spinning into the open into the
public space and this is what has
happened and that actually undermines
the sense of the elite as well that
things are going according to plan
because a precaution is allowed to
attack and accuse the minister of
defense and the command of the Russian
forces of treason it's now getting to
the level where the question is is Putin
really in control of his own man
depending on what Ukraine achieves
will or will not intensify a political
process in Russia so in that sense what
happens inside Russia politically will
be determined by the success of this
counter offensive
the battlefield continues to shape
politics in a way that we haven't seen
since the Second World War
if Ukraine is successful I think the
infighting in Russia will intensify I
think Putin's Position will start
shifting
if Ukraine is not successful however and
it does get stuck you know trading a bit
of territory uh I think Putin will come
out stronger politically and that will
allow him possibly to conduct another
wave of mobilization I think he can only
do immobilization successfully at this
stage if he can show some success on the
battlefield in the face of losing
territory and be and suffering uh
defeats I think that mobilizing people
uh and the elites will actually get a
lot harder and we could see more
unraveling and More infighting in Russia
which is exactly in a way what Ukraine
and the West want to achieve
thank you for watching and if you'd like
to read more of our coverage on Ukraine
and the war please click on the link